and when football gets rolling next week
with the texans and the chiefs on
thursday night
let's focus on some of the teams that
you've pegged as contenders rodney and
let's start with the afc
who do you like coming out of that
conference or at least emerging as the
teams to watch
well my top three mike would be
obviously number one is kansas city you
got a bunch of returning starters
obviously patrick mahomes
i like the ravens i just think that
upgraded um on the defensive line i
think that's going to help stop the run
and i love the tennessee titans
with mike vrabo the coaching and just
their improvement
i'm gonna tell you though my sneaky team
is definitely the pittsburgh steelers i
look at the pittsburgh steelers and
you know that awesome defense i think
that's a super bowl winning defense
you know you get ben roethlisberger back
that helps the defense it helps the
offense and
um those are my top three three teams
with pittsburgh being sneaking the afc
mic
well how about where's your new england
patriots like just give me your you know
what's your feel there because i'm
excited about new england
i understand there's some changing you
know different pieces there
but like give me your you know crystal
ball how do you think this kind of
shakes out for the patriots and cam
newton
well the reason why you say that and i
say that and we're fans of the new
england patriots it's even with tom
brady gone we know they have coach
belichick
but to me you look at mohammed sunu and
him being cut
and released you look and say what other
veteran receiver that they have
on the roster other than julian edelman
and i actually feel sorry for julian
edelman because he's going to see a lot
more double teams
his life is going to be a lot more
difficult not having
those receivers so it's up to bill
belichick he saved six and a half
million dollars on the cap
you got to go out there and get some
playmakers guys that can stretch to feel
some veteran experience to help out
these young guys
and rodney when you mention the ravens
and the chiefs as two of the contenders
in the afc yeah
obviously those are the teams at the top
the titans are the ones that got my
attention because
i feel like a lot of people are
overlooking the titans and maybe that's
just
what the titans are destined to be maybe
they could win the super bowl and still
be overlooked
but i i just and maybe this plays into
their into their hands
the idea that that you're one of the
very few that would put them in that
upper echelon of the afc what do you see
about them
building on what they did last year
repeating what they did last year
to get to the final four to get to
kansas city for the afc championship
game and maybe this year they can get
past it
mike i look at the top man and i look at
mike brabel i played with mike gregor
for a long time i know what he stands
for i know
how his players respect him and i know
what type of players he have he has a
lot of unselfish guys guys that run
through the brick wall for one another
and guys that are cohesive they can run
the football and they have a really good
solid defense they don't make a lot of
mistakes on the defensive side of the
ball
and and i think ryan tanner here was a
very very good quarterback i think he
could do a lot
of things he could pass the ball down
the field he can run he can scramble
and he brings that emotion and that
energy so
i like the tennessee titans they may not
be a fancy team where people are looking
at and they have all these big name
guys but they have a lot of talent
johnny smith they can run the football
i like the titans man don't sleep on
them well
why we're just there because you're on
the titans like the afc south
is going to be interesting i mean we
know desean watson's there jacksonville
okay they're rebuild or whatever you
want to call it there
i just like real quick what do you what
do you what do you see for the
indianapolis colts you know i'm a guy
that i look at them and go
they'd be one of my watch out for them
this year type of teams
uh what what's your feeling on them
rodney hey chris that's a good point
because
indianapolis when i was talking to our
producer matt casey that was one of
the teams that i was actually going to
put down was the indianapolis coach
because they have stability at that
offensive line some you know something
to protect philip rivers i like their
wide receiving core
and what they've done in the draft
getting a young running back and getting
a wide receiver
i like what they're doing down in
indianapolis i get i think phillip
rivers gives them
the stability that they're looking for
the experience especially behind the
experience offensive line
all right rodney you've given us plenty
to think about on the afc side who are
your contenders on the nfc side
well number one would have to be chris
best friend
san francisco 49ers i like the 49ers
i like seattle in the same division and
surprisingly i took the saints off
and i put the tampa bay buccaneers on
there for just whatever reason i like
tampa bay with
all the experienced guys they have
they're loaded and really my sneaky team
would be the arizona cardinals i think
colin murray is going to be a superstar
i love kenyan drake we talked so much
about deandre hopkins but kenyan drake
is a guy that can break open in the open
field and i think he's highly underrated
as a running back
and rodney that that cardinals team is
one that chris and i have been pegging
for months now that we just we can sense
it coming and we saw
patrick mahomes in year two become the
mvp lamar jackson in year two become the
mvp i think kyla murray is gonna make a
run at it this year he's gonna
he's gonna be that guy that's gonna
shock a lot of people because because
most people didn't see him last year but
we all saw enough of them to say
this guy's special mike and that's the
disadvantage of playing on the west
coast i played there with the
san diego chargers for nine years and
unfortunately that's how you get bypass
from
player defensive player of the year and
pro bowls and stuff like that when
you're all the way on the west coast
because a lot of people especially if
you're losing people don't pay attention
to you
but i think with kyle murray i think
that's going to change he is a superstar
he's unselfish they're starting to put
some weapons around them
and i can't wait to see what he does
this year i i mean i agree with all the
kyler murray stuff
i don't know if i could get behind the
sleeper in the nfc
quite yet all right i'll just say that i
love i i got to see their defense play
at a little bit of a higher level
those types of chris who would you
replace it with
well oh you mean just as far as sleepers
are concerned well i mean
i don't know if sleepers are concerned
if we're talking about any team that
didn't make the playoffs last year
damn i probably would like the rams or
the cowboys more than them
okay just as far as complete football
teams i understand the kyler murray love
affair so that would be my teams
but wait i have one more thing for you
because i'd be interested to hear this i
mean we're all in agreement we think the
49ers are a really damn good football
team
talk to us a little bit about what is it
like to come
out of a year losing the super bowl and
what does it do to your psyche early on
in the year or how you know
how does the next season shape up in a
player's mind when you're coming off
like a devastating loss
like they did yeah i think obviously it
depends on what type of makeup you have
in the locker room but for the most part
guys are looking saying look guys we
reached the super bowl we made this
mistake that mistake these are things
that we can improve on
and get better at and i think this is a
confident team they know they have the
great defense they know they can run the
ball
you talk about kyle shanahan's
creativity with play calling all these
different things
so this is you know this is something
that you get excited about you're like
man you know what we lost the super bowl
but we can definitely get back we know
the improvements that we have to make we
got rid of some guys we added some
new guys and it's about chemistry so i
think san francisco
they're primed and ready understanding
their opportunity this year chris
we talk all the time about teams that
had a great season that ended in
disappointment we talked earlier this
week about the ravens going 14-2
and and then you start into a new season
and you keep thinking about last year
maybe if this year it doesn't go as
easily how did bill belichick manage
to get you guys each and every year
to just forget about last year whether
it's a super bowl
whether it's losing in the super bowl
whether it's losing in the playoffs
how what does he do what magic wand does
he wave to get the locker room to forget
completely about last year and focus on
this year
i think his perspective mike i think you
know he he provides us with perspective
and he says you know
what you did last year you know it's
going a completely different team than
what you're dealing with right now at
this point so
don't worry about what happened last
year one game at a time and i think it
comes down from the coach it trickles
down
to the veteran players and it's the same
approach like if the veteran players
approach it
where it's just okay that was last year
we're not thinking about it he doesn't
bring up
what happened last year or anything like
that he completely forgets about it and
he moves forward
and i think once the veterans take that
and trickle it trickles down to the
younger players
then that's when it's played throughout
your locker room okay
one of the teams you talked about with
your nfc contenders there you know
seattle right you know seattle there's
all this talk rodney of like can we put
the ball in russell wilson's hands more
you know i don't know do you think they
did enough on the defensive side of the
ball
to like legitimately put themselves in
that super bowl conversation and listen
i'm with you
i just know these are the questions i
get sometimes too
uh i'm a believer in seattle as well but
anything about their team that jumps out
to you or do you like to see
changed about them uh in any way you
know
chris seattle is just a funny team
because you just can't it's a lot of
times you can't film because
you know like defensively sometimes
they're they're really good on offense
and a lot of you know and then
they might be average on defense and
then you see the potential with some
individual players
on the defensive side of the ball i just
look at the stability of russell wilson
i look at that run game
um i look at that big physical offensive
line and i just
and i think i think the seattle seahawks
are that team that's what
that's ready to take that next step i
just think they're ready to take that
next step yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports